et j'ai une qui a pris du poids pendant
l'été on se dit des choses sachant un
peu combien
alors sur un an je suis à plus 10 à peu
près ah oui plus 10 et oui on dirait pas
comme ça
il est menteur là je connais depuis
longtemps en fait à chaque fois il dit
non mais je suis comme ça parce que j'ai
plus dit c'est je vais les perdre on la
connaît l'histoire des comme j'essaie
mais il faudrait peut-être que suivre
les méthodes de temps que les trucs durs
bon Alexandra on dirait pas là-dedans
je suis très attention moi j'essaie de
de faire attention mais je suis arrivé
là parce que j'entends tout et son
contraire on va pouvoir
la vérité Isabelle je vous demande pas
si vous avez pris du poids vous êtes
toujours filiforme je me pèse jamais oh
c'est une question de répartition des
masses mais je prends quatre par jour
ah bon 3 œufs par jour non pas du tout
c'était une vieille notion c'était une
vieille notion pendant longtemps on a
pensé que le les œufs ça comptait du
cholestérol donc que c'était dangereux
et en fait on sait maintenant que
seulement 25% du cholestérol est produit
par l'alimentation donc en fait comme
les œufs sont rassasiants ça empêche les
gens de manger d'autres choses donc
finalement il y a moins de limites sur
les œufs que ce qu'on mettait aux
paroles
on va vous donner des conseils moi j'ai
été très interpellé par ce sondage parce
qu'on vous a demandé docteur un sondage
des chiffres pour expliquer ce qui nous
regardent effectivement de quoi il
retournait après l'été et bien sondage
les Français prennent en moyenne 3 à 5
kilos 3 à 5 kg pendant l'été c'est une
enquête qui toque qui qui sort ce film
ça me paraît énorme docteur 300 kg alors
quoi c'est le barbecue c'est il y a deux
effets conjugués le premier effet c'est
la relaxation c'est-à-dire c'est les
vacances on ressent moins si on a pris
du poids le fait d'avoir pris du poids
le deuxième effet c'est la convivialité
et la détente ça veut dire que qui toute
l'année tous les soirs prend l'apéro
avec un petit verre de rosé chips etc
les petits déjeuners avec modération les
petits déjeuners beaucoup les sauts
pendant l'année les vacances allez on va
s'acheter une petite viennoiserie et à
la fin c'est on monte sur la balance mon
Dieu 3 à 5 kilos mon Dieu vite j'appelle
machin du chemin et il va s'occuper de
moi
je comprends l'effet convivialité tout
ça mais il y a un truc que je comprends
pas docteur c'est en hiver on a plus
tendance à manger à faire des cheat meal
quoi des grosses pizza des trucs bien
lourds et l'été on a plutôt envie de
frais de salade enfin de choses plus
légères donc comment on explique cette
cette différence là mais parce que
d'abord et puis là on parle des aliments
de façon traditionnelle mais par exemple
pendant l'été on mange plus facilement
une glace pendant les thés on va plus
facilement une viennoiserie quand on
fait un barbecue on va pas mettre un
morceau de rumsteak grillé on va mettre
une chipolatas une merguez et puis on va
faire durer le repas free alcool avec
modération bien sûr mais là il y a pas
de modération et puis dans l'après-midi
s'il y a une petite crête qui passe par
là manger donc un after après être sorti
alors vraiment et puis tout ça ça sent
pas parce que on est bien on est détente
le il est élastique c'est pas comme le
costumes et tout voilà pourquoi c'est
incroyable c'est qu'on se prive avant
l'été pour avoir un body Sommer et après
une fois qu'on arrive en vacances c'est
fini moi je suis pas contre ça
honnêtement je suis pas contre ça je
veux dire la nutrition quand elle est
vécue comme quelque chose de négatif et
punitif c'est une frustration et
finalement on finit par manger plus la
nutrition positive c'est autoriser les
gens à manger avec une harmonie
intelligente et en respectant des
proportions mais le temps des vacances
et le temps des vacances et vous verrez
que pendant les fêtes ça sera exactement
la même chose vive mon métier
c'est un éternel recommencement on va
peut-être passer par on va peut-être
passer à vos conseils docteur premier
conseil à observer si vous aussi vous
avez pris quelques kilos pendant l'été
quelle est la première recette miracle
mais d'abord tout le monde va faire ses
courses la première des choses à faire
n'allez jamais le ventre vide faire les
courses parce que vous n'achèterez pas
ce que vous devez acheter vous allez
acheter ce que vous avez envie d'acheter
et c'est là où les aliments vous et vous
disent viens vers moi vers moi d'accord
donc il faut être voilà faut être
rassasié pour aller à l'essentiel c'est
ça ou ne pas être tenté par des bonbons
des gâteaux et je ne sais pas encore
exactement ça deuxième conseil préparez
les courses avant pour ne pas faire
d'achat d'impulsion c'est-à-dire parce
que oui parce que le en fait les
ménagères d'avant elle faisait ça ça
veut dire que les ménagères alors
c'était un terme générique ça peut être
les hommes ou les femmes mais elle
faisait ça ou il faisait ça c'est-à-dire
qu'il préparait une liste et on savait
ce qu'on allait manger dans la semaine
d'abord on connaissait le prix de ce
qu'on allait dépenser et puis on avait
préparé l'avance on fait pas comme
aujourd'hui on ouvre le frigo ah ouais
il y a ça à manger bah tiens je vais me
préparer ça ou alors allez on va passer
un petit coup de fil on va faire du du
de la demande c'est à dire je veux pas
dire la marque donc on va faire on va se
faire livrer et quand vous regardez bien
les sites de livraison il y a quoi pizza
sushi kebab burger voilà taille de 30
ans et en fait ce sont des produits qui
vont nous faire grossir donc c'est très
important de savoir ce qu'on va manger à
l'avance surtout si on veut se mettre au
régime les sushis ça fait grossir bah
quand vous en prenez moi dans les
régimes moi aussi
les sujets d'avance c'était du poisson
et du riz aujourd'hui j'ai des sushis
Sacha il connaît parce qu'il fréquent
les mêmes magasins que moi ils sont pas
nés avec des fois du foie gras
maintenant il y a plein de trucs alors
moi je suis pas très poisson cru mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a c'est vrai que
maintenant il rajoute plein de trucs il
y a des sauces sucrées il y a bon il y a
plein de sushi poisson si on en prend 8
pour les femmes et 12 pour les hommes
parce qu'il dépense un peu plus
d'énergie à cause de musculature pour
beaucoup d'entre eux bah ça marche oui
bien sûr on peut manger des sushis mais
est-ce qu'on va se limiter ça les sushis
dont vous parlez dans les hamburgers ça
fait hurler plein de twittos et plein de
gens sur les réseaux quand je dis il y a
des bons produits dans les fast food il
y a des sandwichs de temps en temps qui
sont bien composé le problème c'est vous
allez prendre les frites vous allez pas
les prendre si vous prenez le hamburger
autorise le hamburger avec un fruit mais
j'autorise pas les frites
c'est grosso modo ça tourne entre 350 et
520 calories pour les burgers corrects
je vous parle pas de ouais ouais des
classiques donc bon 500 calories s'il
est correctement composé avec un fruit
pour faire des fibres ok ça change la
vision d'un régime c'est-à-dire quand
vous faites ça vous changer l'idée du
régime
avec le burger c'est génial vous allez
avoir peur vous êtes un nombre de
patients
moi je me remusque l'été et à la rentrée
j'ai dit oh mais demain et je fais plus
de gym du tout donc d'un seul coup je
passe de tout à rien il y a pas un
aliment qui aide à qui donne envie de
faire du sport on augmente un peu les
protéines quoi mais les œufs là très
bonne idée troisième conseil que vous
nous donnez docteur avoir toujours en
réserve dans le réfrigérateur des
yaourts classiques ou des yaourts
végétaux oui en fait il faut avoir des
produits qui ont une connotation propre
diététiquement quand vous ouvrez le
frigo
vous comprenez Si on a acheté on a
acheté du comté où on a acheté je sais
pas on voit traîner des trucs dans le
frigo on va les prendre mais quand je
tombe sur le yaourt la compote de fruits
même le yaourt végétal ou des produits
qui ont une connotation diététique si je
vais jusqu'à les consommer ça
m'empêchera de prendre autre chose
d'accord qu'est-ce que vous avez contre
le pontet 400 calories au 100 g 31% de
matière grasse tout ce qui s'explique
c'est bon les 10 kg j'ai compris
j'adore ça aussi
Isabelle les gens vont condamner le foie
gras le foie gras c'est à peu près 450
calories 100 g 39 % de matière grasse
que des monoinsaturés c'est à dire des
graisses qui décrochent le cholestérol
des artères mais le comté non
excusez-moi allez donc ça va on peut en
manger bien sûr mais ce que je veux dire
par là les gens ils connaissent pas tout
ça c'est les fameuses rumeurs dont tu
parles alors il y a des gens qui passent
leur vie à tout interdire mais en même
temps je vous dis on peut manger du
comté on peut manger du foie gras le
problème c'est à chaque fois de
l'organiser dans le repas voilà et la
quantité quatrième conseil que vous
donnez limiter non non mais c'est
parfait limiter au maximum les matières
grasses au moment de la cuisson ça c'est
la cuisine au beurre on oublie quoi non
c'est pas ça c'est que on parle toujours
du sucre caché du sel caché on parle pas
de la graisse cachée par exemple quand
on fait une salade moi je dis aux gens
prenez une cuillère à soupe pour mesurer
vous mettez une cuillère à soupe d'huile
bon dans notre tradition moi je viens
d'Afrique du Nord donc voilà il connaît
le geste on prend la bouteille
deux cuillères à soupe et 100 calories
donc bon bah oui cuillère
ma première oui parce que j'ai quitté
elle m'a quitté plus exactement ma
première fiancée quand elle faisait
cuire un steak elle prenait la plaquette
de beurre dans la poêle ah c'est bon
c'était super bon mais alors franchement
bon ben c'est ce que j'appelle les
matières grasses cachées four à
micro-ondes rôtissoire braisé c'est pour
ça que vous l'avez quitté non non parce
qu'elle me trompait tout le temps
d'aromatiser ces animaux pour leur
donner du goût mais pas avec du sel bien
sûr parce qu'on a aromatisé en France on
a la culture de la Grèce et du sel et en
fait quand on connaît les épices j'ai
passé un bon moment avec Mokhtar ceux
qui mettent du cumin du coriandre du
persil de la ciboulette ceux qui vont
mettre du curcuma ceux qui vont mettre
un jus de citron changer les vinaigre à
prendre des vinaigre originaux bah oui
ça donne du goût aux aliments la donne
envie en même temps quand on voit
l'image effectivement
tout ce qui est ketchup Mayo tout ça
c'est à bannière aussi non alors je suis
un grand défenseur du ketchup je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi parce que ketchup
quand il est light c'est 14 g de sucre
pour 100 g quand il est pas light c'est
24 g au maximum on en met deux cuillères
à soupe aux enfants ça fait 20 g donc en
fait les gosses ils vont prendre même
pas l'équivalent d'un carré dessus les
parents disent arrow sur le ketchup mais
allez-y sur les bons becs donc en fait
le ketchup nos enfants de manger en plus
le ketchup c'est de la tomate cuite et
donc c'est du lycopène actif c'est un
antioxydant puissant donc le ketchup ne
paye pas pour dire ça donc les
nutritionnistes américains moi-même et
beaucoup d'autres de mes confrères de
compétents on sait que c'est pas grave
bien sûr si tu prends le pot de ketchup
ça va pas mais deux cuillères à soupe ça
va sixième conseil essayez de faire des
repas complets c'est à dire entrer plein
dessert
la tendance quand vous êtes au régime
c'est en général de dire moins je mange
plus maigris c'est pas vrai d'abord
manger est un travail ça veut dire ça
coûte de l'énergie au corps et la
deuxième chose c'est quand vous êtes
rassasié vous ne grignoterez pas et le
grignotage c'est en fait des calories
cachées la plupart du temps quand je
vais la folie des amendes par exemple
les gens prennent une poignée d'amande
ok les gars prenez deux cuillères à
soupe d'huile c'est pareil de toute
façon
mais oui c'est désolé agineux donc avec
les amendes
c'est la folie des aliments magiques
c'est la folie des aliments magiques et
tous les influenceurs qui connaissent
pas grand-chose dans ton régime il faut
que tu mettes trois cuillères à soupe
d'amandes tous les jours et le gars dit
mais je maigris pas bah ouais c'est
normal et 300 calories de plus
d'amande mais hamburger ketchup c'est
bon
en même temps
attention aux jeunes intermittents aussi
c'est à dire de prolonger pendant une
grande période petite précision le jeune
intermittent c'est un régime qui est né
quand j'ai écrit un livre en 2015 qui
s'appelait j'ai décidé de maigrir dans
lequel j'ai parlé pour la première fois
du jeune intermittent j'ai bien expliqué
que le jeune intermittent il faut
pendant les 8 heures où on mange c'est
pas il y a 16h moins je sais pas 8h on
mange si vous voulez maigrir il faut
respecter des contrats alimentaires si
vous mangez tout ce que vous voulez
pendant le jeûne intermittent vous
grossirez exemple le ramadan un tiers de
ceux qui font le ramadan c'est un jeune
intermittent maigrisse un tiers grossi
un tiers prend du poids donc c'est
vraiment ça dépendra de ce que vous
mangez pendant les mineurs tout entendu
oui non ça m'a servi moi je m'en servais
quand je l'ai créé je m'en servais pour
accélérer pour donner un coup de boost à
un régime de temps en temps on
s'entourage c'est très chiant pour
l'entourage
petit déjeuner oui et vous dégénère mais
beaucoup de gens en fait chez qui ça
marche c'est qu'en fait il saute un
repas en réalité ils ont enlevé un repas
simplement alors qu'en fait il faut
distribuer les repas sur 8 heures oui
c'est ça pendant 16 heures on s’arrête
de manger voilà pendant 16 heures et
quand on s'arrête de ma jambe on peut
boire de l'eau du thé du café mais faut
pas prévu privilégier plutôt les repas
pendant la journée et éviter le soir de
manger pas de règles pour manger
oui pardon il y a un truc dont on ne
parle jamais c'est la nécessité de
mâcher beaucoup oui moi je suis dans un
entourage où les gens avalent tout rond
bah oui tout le monde
et histoire de vous faire rire il y
avait un médecin qui voulait faire
maigrir les gens au début du 20e siècle
il disait il faut mâcher autant de fois
que vous avez de nombre d'années donc je
me disais pour les mecs de 70 ans c'est
quand même galère non mais c'est ça
quand vous mâchez vous maigrissez est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça
donc la digestion est plus harmonieuse
et donc vous ralentissez la digestion et
donc vous vous atteindrez plus
facilement la satiété d'accord donc
manger doucement c'est peut-être un
conseil aussi à docteur vous nous avez
donné plein de conseils ce qui est un
régime particulier à suivre pour ceux
qui veulent vraiment vraiment perdre du
poids alors on peut faire des régimes
très actifs très restrictifs par exemple
vous pouvez faire des régimes où vous
mangez des œufs beaucoup le matin le
midi le soir avec juste des légumes ou
des bouillons de légumes et un yaourt le
problème de ces régimes c'est qu'ils
sont très difficiles donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut être un soldat et derrière il
va falloir faire une réadaptation douce
moi je préfère commencer par des régimes
très harmonieux et très doux et les
durcir au moment où il y a des plateaux
de stabilisation voilà c'est
éternels
des conseils s'affiche sur l'écran il y
a deux été docteur j'avais fait un
régime full pastèque pendant l'été et
j'avais perdu grave des kilos est-ce que
c'est bien ou c'est dangereux pour la
santé full pastèque pendant l'été mais
combien de temps pas de moi
si tous les régimes restrictifs sont
dangereux c'est-à-dire que pour avoir
une bonne santé il faut couvrir la
totalité des aliments la meilleure des
alimentations et le meilleur des régimes
c'est celui qui n'interdit rien ça veut
dire que parce qu'on réapprend aux gens
à manger quand je fais un régime que
pastèque même quand tu as mangé trois
kilos de pastèque au bout d'un moment tu
as mangé 30 fois 30 calories tu as fait
un régime à 900 calories centré sur des
fibres et un peu de sucre c'est pas top
c'est comme les gens qui faisaient les
régimes tout raisins quoi d'accord donc
c'est pas top et c'est pour ça que tu es
comme ça aujourd'hui
des enfants parce qu'on parle juste
bonne ambiance
docteur je voudrais juste qu'on dise
aussi un mot sur les enfants parce que
il y a de plus en plus d'enfants de
petits Français qui souffrent d'obésité
et parfois les enfants aussi il faut les
mettre au régime non alors jusqu'à l'âge
de 11 ans en réalité les enfants sont
pas autonome alimentairement donc ça
veut dire que c'est un peu comme
l'éducation d'une façon générale il y a
une éducation alimentaire qui est donnée
par les parents quand vous mettez les
enfants trop tôt au régime vous créez
des étapes frustration et après ils
jettent sur la nourriture par la suite
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment que ils
sont obligés de manger en se cachant
pour pour pouvoir se faire plaisir après
l'âge de 11 ans on attend en général la
demande des enfants vous savez on en a
marre de ces régimes à répétition ça
veut dire des gens qui veulent faire des
régimes restrictifs trop rapides trop
durs et puis qui maigrissent puis qui
reprennent puis qui ont maigrissent ça
change le tissu adipeux donc on attend
que l'enfant est fait un peu de sport on
l'éduque ensuite on attend qu'il ait
fait un peu de sport et ensuite on
essaye tout doucement de lui montrer ce
que sont critère de l'alimentation avant
l'adolescence
travailler quand même ça veut dire pas
question de les abandonner comme ça et
de leur donner quand ils partent à
l'école allez la bride de jus de pomme
et le paquet de biscuits quoi c'est donc
les enfants peut-être donner ce sera
votre dernier conseil
normalement c'est un petit bout de pain
un petit bout de fromage un yaourt ou un
fruit ou les deux voilà ou alors de
temps en temps on leur donne certains
biscuits alors je vais pas donner les
marques mais c'est les petites navettes
avec de la confiture ou bien un petit
bout de pain avec du chocolat et un
yaourt et un fruit ou bien on peut leur
donner vous savez ces petites paillettes
là farcies puis on rajoute le yaourt et
le fruit il faut pas être trop punitif
on peut donner des céréales le problème
des céréales c'est que les enfants ont
pris l'habitude de les grignoter avec
les doigts et il laisse tomber le
produit laitier alors que les produits
laitiers c'est important chez les
enfants voilà donc pas de régime pour
les enfants des conseils pour les goûter
et nous on voit tous faire attention
après il était merci